it's okay it's okay it's okay it's okay
if you're lost we're all a little lost
and it's all right
america's got talent contestant
nightbird has died she was 31. it's a
song i wrote for myself in the middle of
the night when i needed those words so
bad
and it's um
it's beautiful to see
the world
welcome that song into their own dark
night and
uh i
i'm overwhelmed by it nightbird's family
announced on instagram that she died on
february 19th after her four-year battle
with cancer her loved ones also shared
this video of the singer whose real name
is jane marchetsky talking about grief
just because you're sad or grieving
doesn't mean that you're not grateful
and it doesn't mean you're not hopeful
it doesn't mean that you still aren't
fighting for your life that you still
don't have it in you to keep going but
sadness and grief and
mourning
and lamenting
and crying and screaming and being angry
these are ways that we honor what was
lost the family writes it's like jane
knew the word she needed to leave us
with before she left we hope her words
comfort you as you all mourn
be sad and be grateful
and look at the twinkly lights and feel
your feelings and
it's all real the joy and the pain is
all
real and you don't have to pick one or
the other life is beautiful or life is
garbage
it's kind of both sometimes also sharing
their grief agt judge simon cowell he
gave knight bird his golden buzzer
during season 16 auditions
i'm not going to give you a yes
[Music]
i'm gonna give you something else
[Music]
simon writes in a post heartbreaking
news to hear about nightbird she was an
extraordinary person so brave so
talented she made a huge impact on agt
and the world her courage was incredible
and her determination to fight this
terrible illness was remarkable rest in
peace jane i cannot say thank you enough
for the opportunity to to have a moment
to share my story of course knight
bird's story came to light during the
talent competition when she performed an
original tune titled it's okay it's okay
it's okay it's okay it's okay
[Music]
shortly after her moving performance the
songstress announced she was exiting the
competition to focus on her health i
know that the last time we spoke you you
actually said you feel like you let
people down well i just want to say on
behalf of all of us you haven't let
anyone down
even though you haven't competed you've
already won but saying goodbye wasn't
easy your clip has had such an impact on
so many people and your courage and who
you are and on behalf of all of us here
we're sending you our love our prayers
and we can't wait to see you again soon
and thank you so much for auditioning on
the show and from for singing such a
beautiful song and
you know it was
simon told et at the time knight bird's
exit was a choice they made together i
did speak to her today and i said i'm
calling you because i know how you must
be feeling you know because she may well
you actually the two of us made the
decision for her not to enter the
competition because of the stress
um
would she have won tonight
i think she probably would actually
and there's no doubt nightbird won
making an everlasting impact with her
talent and resilience
[Music]
all right
to be lost sometimes
wow
you